strategic they write native speakers
correct it
and they have courses italki and shared
talk if i'm not mistaken
they're both language exchange sites
primarily
and i mean this is just four if you
start looking for
you know you know learn french language
exchange you name it
there are just pages and pages of the
stuff and we're only just beginning
so only the good ones will survive so i
believe that
this kind of exchange can only get
better you know another tremendous
resource
is google translate and i mean anyone
who has to deal with more than one
language
should be aware of google translate
because you can type in
english choose your language from
however many 50 languages choose the
direction you want to go to
it'll translate it and you can listen to
it
and very often if you get something in
another language you just pop it in
there
it works very well for european
languages it doesn't work quite so well
for japanese in fact
if i put japanese in there what comes up
is garbage
but here is uh
my russian site this is an amazing
resource
i every day for the last two three years
i listen to at least 30 to 40 minutes
of this radio station and what they give
you is they have every day they have
like
it's a it's a news talk commentary radio
station that's all they do
and so every interview is put up there
and it's got
the text and the sound and so i download
it
i listen to the audio the text i import
into my system and i'll show you how our
system works
so that i can convert new words and
phrases into flashcards in the things
that i can learn
but i mean i followed from that time of
the war in georgia through
the latest developments in russian
politics and i've improved my russian to
the extent
that because i'm a member of this
economy
uh and actually so they approached me
and they said would you do a blog
because they they found out that i'm a
sort of a member of the ecommerce league
club here in vancouver and there's like
300.
and they asked all the people who were
part of echo must be
if any of them would be willing to do a
blog as a lead up to the olympics
so i said sure so i had a blog
and i would go out and take pictures of
preparations no snow on cypress all this
stuff
and so that was fine and then i had a
phone call
from them and they said that we would
like to do an interview with you
and i said sure and they said we'd like
to talk about uh
what's it called triathlon i say i don't
know anything about triad funds
well how about hockey i said that's fine
so the next thing i know i get a phone
call
and i did a live interview in russia
in moscow with vladislav treject
who is the head of the russian ice
hockey federation
and he asked me who i thought was going
to win the gold medal and all this kind
of stuff
and we had a chat for three minutes
which for me having started
russian four years ago having spent most
of my time with
stuff on this website to be interviewed
by them with blind left track jack was
like
you know i was very happy so
i have some sites for portuguese and
stuff like that so there's so many
resources there
all right no of course people are going
to say yeah but
you know what about the curriculum the
test speaking correct correctly all this
kind of stuff
so i what i would like to do here is i
would like to show you
what we do at our site for language
learning and how we deal with this issue
of
not texts we don't have tests but how we
get people to speak correctly
and how we sort of marshal the resources
of
you know all kinds of people who the
learners become teachers
and i should point out that i have tried
to interest let's say that the
federal government for immigrants for
example and there's just no way like
you're totally against it
and their arguments are like for example
you know
uh what credentials do your teachers
have
and i said well our teachers actually
the learners and
but all we really care about is that
they can speak their own language well
and that they're cheerful and
encouraging and
nice to the other learners and that
seems to work quite well and i said in
fact
research shows that there is no
relationship between
teachers credentials and effectiveness
like zero
verbal communication skills uh knowledge
of their subject matter
uh enthusiasm all these things track two
results
credentials don't track the results but
that's a whole other issue
anyway so if i
okay we're going to now go into a four
minute
video that alex prepared about our site
hi and welcome to link this is the
welcome page
you will notice that we can select from
several different languages at the top
let's choose french since
it's our first time studying french
unlink the system will suggest that we
choose our first lesson
let's go ahead and do that
upon entering the library we are met
with a dialog box
asking for our level there are several
levels to choose from
ranging from no knowledge at all to
advanced
system will suggest lessons to us based
on our level
let's choose beginner one
you'll notice that there are several
suggested lessons
some of which have been created by us
but several others that have been
created by members of link
let's choose eating out part one
welcome to the work desk this is where
we can study our lessons
you'll notice that all the words are
highlighted in blue this is because they
are new words
mouse over one of these words and you
can see the top three user hints
select the one that you like most
you've just created a link you'll notice
that the word is changed from blue to
yellow
this word will appear yellow in every
future lesson
you'll notice on the right that we can
also listen to the text
excuse me a
let's create links of other words that
we don't know
all of these links that we create will
be saved as flashcards
on the right they will also appear
yellow in every future lesson
once we have finished selecting unknown
words
we can click i know all
a box appears telling us that words have
been added to our known words total
and you'll notice that all the blue
words have changed to white
these words are known words and will
appear white in every future lesson
we can continue on to the next lesson in
the collection if we like
but let's take a look at the profile
page
you'll notice that progress has
automatically been recorded
including the words that we have read
and the links that we've created
we can use these statistics as a rough
guideline of our progress in the
language
in addition to studying lessons on link
you can also have conversations with
tutors have your writings corrected by
native speakers
and use the forum to interact with other
members of the site
link is a community it is a language
learning system
that promotes interaction with the
language and with others
at the friends page we can see lessons
that others have been studying
we can select a specific language and
see
what members studying a similar language
have been up to
if we go down and select steve
we can see his profile
link is a place where you can study
languages from the comfort of your own
home
yet have access to thousands of other
language learners
only a click away
yeah so uh you know it's an example
i mentioned live moca itake there's
many many i would imagine there's
hundreds of such communities
uh what we do i think is you can have a
personal tutor you can download the
sound to listen to on your ipod which is
the
my major activity